[Arabic recitation]
chapter number 73
of the book of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
We stopped last night at verse number
10.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala we have to
look here to the relationship
between the verses and the topics that
are addressed in those verses.
This chapter
is narrative its central narrative and
its center thrust is that of prayer and
connection to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Now
often times when a person has enemies
lurking,
when a person has enemies working day
and night
to plot and plan and prod.
It's very easy for a person to become
overly consumed with his enemy.
And so in this chapter, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala is commanding the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
stand for prayer at night most of the
night is preferable half or a little
less than half and recite the Quran
slowly and methodically.
Contemplate the Quran and
doing so is going to take away from your
sleep. And so you're going to have to
sacrifice that sleep for this prayer.
And that sacrifice will have to be
compensated for during the day.
Now, as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
him this, he then addresses his enemies,
our prophet's enemies. Why? Because it's
easy for a person to say, "Well, well,
I'm here busy reading and reciting and
making dua and making salah. My enemies
are out there getting busy. My enemies
are getting ahead.
But Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
tells him,
"And don't think that this is because
you have forgotten your enemies. You
haven't forgotten them. Neither have we.
However, be patient with that which they
say
and boycott them in the best of ways.
Because as we mentioned last night,
patience is often times confused with
inaction.
Correct? Patience is often times
confused and conflated with inaction.
that if a person is being patient,
they're not doing anything. No, to the
contrary, patience is action. As a
matter of fact, it is the default
action. Before a person takes action,
any action he takes, whether it be for
good or whether it be for bad, whether
it be for his
for his friend or foe, that action
needs to be based on patience, all
action.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
him, "And be patient with that which
they say and boycott them, abandon them
in the best of ways." What does that
mean?
[Silence]
machine.
Allah says, "And
boycott them in the most beautiful of
ways." A beautiful boycotting, a good
boycotting. If he has described this
boycotting as being good, then that
means there is a bad type of boycotting
as well. Correct?
I'll give you the
what they say. I'll give you the skinny
on what this bad boycotting would be.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
retreats from their gatherings, but then
he starts to spread rumors about them.
When his companions come to meet him and
learn about Allah, he is busy talking to
them about Abu Jah and Abu Leah. And he
came and he left and I saw and I think
he's doing this and I think he's doing
that.
This is boycotting them in a bad way.
He said
and boycott them with poise.
Boycott them with balance.
Doesn't mean that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam didn't warn
his companions of Abu Jah and Abu and
no we've gone through many verses of the
Quran in which Allah
brings them up as a
topic of discussion however it is for
some consequence or for some benefit for
some lesson to be derived not just to
get that venom out it's not coming from
a place of vitriol in venom. It's coming
from a place of regret and we wish
things could be better and we wish these
men would see the light. But those whom
Allah chooses not to guide will never
find guidance. This is the narrative.
Now,
don't think that because the evildoers
are able to get an occasional leg up on
the good, that
falsehood will occasionally
will occasionally rise and cover
the good. Falsehood will occasionally
have a battle or two that it wins.
But falsehood will never win the overall
war ever. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
assures us. He says,
He says that the end result and the
permanent will always be for tawa and
the people of tawa. Always.
Always.
Even if falsehood expounds itself and it
will never have the patience and longe
longevity of the truth. This is
momentary. This is momentary.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
went to how many battles himself?
Here's some trivia,
history trivia. How many battles did he
attend himself?
Three. Oh, my good brother. Not even
close.
[Arabic recitation]
Three. And then we got three times that.
We got nine over there. Anyone else
try twice that
battles he attended himself.
Did he ever lose any one of those
battles?
What's the answer? Yes, he did. Which
battle?
He won at the start but because of the
disobedience he that was later a lost
battle. Did he lose the war? No.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala describes
the mushri and the people of falsehood
as having a what?
Allah subhanahu wa tala
[Silence]
Subh.
And so Allah describes the disbelievers
as having an occasional
an occasional victory here and there.
Has to keep their pallet
a little bit wet for their blood lust.
Why? So that they continue to draw more
rope. So that when they hang themselves
with it, it will be thorough.
[Silence]
So in this verse Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells our prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam be patient. Patience is
not in action.
It is not inaction. It is the basis and
default of action. Especially the wise,
the wise build and base all actions on
patience.
And then he said,
don't allow your companions
to feel and sense that you are bitter.
that when they come to sit with you and
learn about Allah, you can only think
and talk about your enemies.
Let that not be your your haj
rather make your h your boycott of them
and their folly a beautiful one a
boycott of poise and calculation.
Then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to
the prophet Sam,
"And as for Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
he says, leave the disbelieving to me.
Leave them to me.
[Silence]
Don't even worry about them. While you
are spending your time contemplating
your relationship with me, I will spend
I will take care of them in the absence
of your in your in the absence of your
attention to them. Because if I'm
directing my attention to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, I'm not thinking
now about my enemies. Allah will take
care of that for you. And this tells us
what? This tells us that when we
sacrifice something for Allah, Allah
will replace it with that which is
better.
[Silence]
He assures us that whoever leaves off
something for Allah, Allah will replace
it for him with something better.
And so
when you now sacrifice your attention on
your enemies, and they're not just
they're not just it's not just some
passive aggressive group of people,
right? They're a little bit disgruntled,
just some rumors.
These are bloodthirsty,
ignorant idolattors.
People that have no mercy.
And this came at a time when people were
very religious and spiritual. Not like
today.
Today in today's world, people are in in
this part of the world, people are
increasingly
more and more godless and materialistic.
religious is moot to them. It's it's
it's a minute part of their life or
thought. Why? Because they're too
comfortable to think about such silly
things as God and death and the
hereafter and so forth. And so people
make jokes about religion. It's not
important to them. In the time of the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam.
Men would fight to the death over
someone disrespecting their idols.
Someone disrespecting a tree that they
worshiped.
You come along and say this tree
cannot help you with a law, cannot give
you anything nor take anything away from
you. They'll put you to death if they
can for saying that, for disrespecting
our tree. This is how they were. They
were a very arrogant people and a people
that took their idols very seriously.
And so don't think that when the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam came along and
started reciting verses
these to them,
forch.
[Silence]
It didn't fall on ears of people who
took religion not very seriously. These
were a very serious lawless bloody
society that he was sent to saiam.
And sometimes you know when we go to
think about things like
a person
is just born brave. No. Can a person
learn courage?
If a person is naturally inclined to
cowardice, can he learn to be brave?
Yeah. What is the best way to learn
bravery?
Tell me who.
Huh?
Face your fears.
Wrong.
Tell me. Tell me.
Someone comes to you, your son. Your son
comes to you, says, "Dad, I feel like
I'm I want to learn to be courageous. I
want to learn valor. I want to learn
courage. I want to learn bravery." Where
do you start with him?
[Arabic recitation]
slay? Wasallam.
You start by reading the prophet
Muhammad's biography sai
by reading his words. No man ever walked
this earth after him more brave than
that man. alone. Alone the closest of
people abandoned him. And he stood and
with his full chest recited these verses
to a bloody society as they looked at
him with nothing but blood in their
eyes. And he stood alone.
He stood alone. Musam, wasn't he afraid?
Didn't he tell Allah, "I'm afraid." He
said, "I'm afraid." What did Allah say?
Don't be afraid. I am with you. MS
learned how to be courageous. Just like
you can learn how to be generous and you
can learn how to be truthful and you can
learn how to be dutiful and you can
learn how to be kind. That's the beauty
of being a human being is you can change
no matter how old you are. No matter how
long you have been on whatever it is,
you can change at the drop of a hat if
you choose to. If you choose to do so.
And so our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
is told by Allah, you now have to have
the courage to forget about your enemies
and focus on your relationship with
Allah. And if you do that, don't be
worried that they will get the upper
hand on you because you're not giving
them the attention they deserve. No, we
got you.
We will take care of that for you.
Allah assures him. He says, "Leave the
beliers to me. Leave me and the beliers
together. Leave us. Leave us be. Leave
us alone. we will take care of them for
you. He says,
he says, those men who disbelieve in
spite of the incredible amount of luxury
and comfort that they exist in.
[Silence]
Those men who are
just existing between,
you know, the the the the hardest thing
touching their skin is silk.
and the hardest day of their life is a
day when they are too full.
Those men, leave them to me. You focus
on your relationship with Allah. Allah
will in turn focus on your enemies for
you. And when a time comes for you to
take up arms and defend yourself, your
Lord will tell you when that time will
be. And at the end of the chapter, we'll
see that Allah gives an indicator that
that day will eventually come. A day
when the Muslim will be allowed to stand
toe-to-toe with their aggressors.
Foreham.